you know a b don't know nothing
a b is like a blind guy with a damn
hatchet
you know he don't know you from adam bro
you know he'll sting his [ __ ]
stepmother if you give him half a dollar
like a b don't give a damn
if you crack open a b there ain't a damn
in that thing
we had a fella actually when i was
growing up we used to go to summer camp
i think it was summer camp i don't know
they didn't do anything really
they kept us in a damn pavilion out at
the park and it was hot as could be
and everybody had kool-aid mustaches and
everybody had to bring their own lunch
and your lunch your kool-aid would spill
in your lunch thing and it would get all
wet and you had to eat it anyway
so if you haven't had a raspberry
kool-aid grilled cheese sandwich
and we might not know each other
but one thing uh we had a fellow out
there was a groundskeeper
and a groundskeeper basically somebody
that's homeless but also
you know it you know kind of hangs out
in one specific area
and this fella bi they call him he would
uh
he had a glass eye or some type of
textile eye
you know this fella had something happen
you know i'm saying he lost one of them
bad
sight balls and somebody you know hooked
him up with that replica
and he would get b's there were bees
everywhere
b's on every there was bees on
everything bees on every trash can had a
thousand bees on it
and he would take a beat and he would
sting right into his own eye with it
and it would freak the kids out because
we never seen it
and then here you go he's doing it
and he would just get a bee and just
sting and the kids if it was a new kid
or somebody that was coming to camp for
a week
because it was ymca summer camp
so every week is when you get a new kid
in
and sometime it you know some fella or
some little lady come in there
sometime they get the little squirrely
kid with the real pale skin
a couple freckles kind of some dark
freckles curly hair
creeping everybody out
you know real kind of vein you know like
real veiny eyes just
he always had that one little fella
creeping people
and my friend daniel actually this
little fellow would grow on a bus we had
this miscreant fellow
rally man named daniel and he would do
cigarettes man or do
you know he he's uh he um
super glued his own mouth clothes once
and it just whole neighborhood was
furious man
and when they finally got it open he
laughed at everybody
dang
so we had people like that
you know we had real miscreants dude um
we had a fella drank a little bit of
ethanol this kid named todd man and he
looked like
he really looked like [ __ ] but he looked
like [ __ ] before he drank it
so
but uh anyway what was i talking about
man
todd no no no no before that man
daniel no before that uh
oh bees baby
mother nature's freaking pitchforkers
dog
uh and this fellow would just sting his
own eye with him just take him and just
sting right into his own eye because he
had a
not a homemade eye but semi homemade you
know to step up from homemade like maybe
they'd made it in home eck
so he had that you know he had that home
back eye and he would just and if you
didn't know the
new kids didn't know so every time after
lunch he'd get a kid
over there and get his get a live b and
sting his own eye with it
geez you have any uh unique individuals
or role models like that growing up
riley
oh man as far as the like
i don't think i can go that far as like
be singing in
your own eye um other than that no i
mean i've had like
you know there's like those special kids
that are like you know in special ed and
you know i have a few friends in that
too i have a few um blind friends that
are like
super good at you know audio at audio
engineering at my school
um it's crazy listeners huh big
listeners
oh yeah yeah they're like the best
students there we had a guy like that
too
they call him the big listener and he
was blind or something was wrong with
him he said he couldn't see
and people believed him right and he
could hear
he was that freaking that's that
listener
you know he was just damn christopher
columbus on the listenership man he was
just
and we had a blind kid that could play
kickball real well
and he could hear the ball rolling feel
it on the ground
and kick it just the damn willie nelson
of kickball just the real
i mean this guy was just
just damn kirby puckett man this fella
old fat leg he had a fat leg on him too
a lot of blind people are fat in the
legs
what else we got here man evening good
afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one ah